欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课 同学们 这一节课 我们来讲一下关于店铺流量暴跌 暴增 这种情况怎么样去分析店铺 怎么样找到具体的原因 然后针对性的优化 因为我们店铺在推广和在操作的过程中 不可能是流量持续的稳定增长的 也会出现店铺过三次一样在波动
那么出现这种情况 我们怎么样去分析呢 比如说暴增 我们要怎么样去分析 然后总结出更好的方法 然后持续的应用这些更好的方法去拉升整个店铺的效果
如果出现了暴跌 那么我们要怎么样去分析 怎么样去找到原因 然后针对这些原因
去针对性的解决问题 让我们店铺的流量变成上升的趋势呢
那么接下来 我们就详细的进行分析 大家可以跟着我的思路去思考 以及对照着后台去判断 去操作 那么关于
店铺流量暴增暴跌的一个分析思路是怎么样的呢
我们去分析店铺的时候 一定是按周按月的数据去对比各项指标的数据 这样的话准确度会更高 如果我们按照天的数据去看 那么很有可能就会出现偶然性
所以说他的数据就不够准确 我们最好就是按照周和月的数据去对比 然后找到具体增长或者是暴跌的指标
所以这些指标进行采取有效的方法去改善 首先 我们来看一下他的整个流程是怎么样的 从左到右 他是从大范围到小范围去进行分析的
这样的话 我们就能够非常精准的找到具体的问题 第一个 我们来看一下店铺综合数据他的一个分析的路径 第一个 我们要去看曝光点击访客返回
这些数据对比周跟月 他有哪些数据指标是下降的 有哪些数据指标是上涨的 那么这个数据怎么看呢 在我们平时
有综合店铺数据表的时候 就用那个表格看就可以了 自然流量跟直动车流量 这些都是在那个表格里面都能够清晰的看出
所以我们前面一定要会做一个店铺综合数据表 这个表格非常的重要 它的数据能够反映出店铺当前的
很多问题 这些数据就能够为我们后期的优化提供数据决策 第三个就是店铺新级
侵权 违规处罚 这些都会影响我们整个店铺的流量 这些会导致流量下降 第四个就是翻货率如果不足80%的话 那么可能就是你
会被评为零星 回复率低的话 那么这些都会影响我们整体的流量的增长 第二个就是我们要去看流量局道的分析
它的分析思路是怎么样的 我们要去看我们这些流量局道 这个局道哪些是增长的 哪些是暴跌的 因为每个局道对应的操作是不一样的
每个局道它的流量涨跌都能够反映出我们要操作的一些具体的内容
第二个就是是否有报名活动和大处的影响 比如说你3月报名活动效果很高 但是过了3月也就是4月5月
没有活动了 那么你很多产品的流量就下降了 就会导致你整个店铺的流量下降
它是一连串的反映的 那么第三个就是系统圈品和平台奖励的资源位置 也就是比如说你3月参加了活动
然后获得了非常好的效果 平台给你奖励资源位 也就是可能在4月的时候给你奖励了一个首页展示的位置
这个位置的流量非常大 你店铺出现了暴增的情况 因为你可能获得了非常有利的资源位
另一个暴增可能就是因为你的产品效果非常好 被系统圈到某一个场景里面去展示 那么也会能够提升你整个产品的效果
产品的效果 那么是不是产品的流量提升了 店铺的效果就提升了 它是一连串的反映
第四个就是你优品 暴增的总量变化 比如说你的优品本来是30 暴增可能是5个 那么到后面变成了15个
一个 那么是不是暴增跟优品减少了 是不是导致流量下降 因为暴增跟优品它能够
占据你整个店铺的总流量的可能在80%都有可能 有些甚至更多的可能占到90%
所以你当你这个优品和暴增数量下降了 是不是
你这里的流量下降 占比下降了其他板块的流量 那20%又没有增长 那么是不是整个店铺的流量
整个店铺的流量就在下降了 就这种原因导致的 所以我们要去看
流量 暴增暴跌的时候 要去看这个流量局当
具体哪个板块下降了 这些都是直接影响到我们店铺流量的
一些重要的指标和因素 第三个
我们就要分析具体的产品了 前面我们从最大的维度 整个店铺全局分析
第二个就是从
店铺的流量来源 也就是能够通过这个路径进入店铺的数据 哪些出现问题
然后出现问题了之后 具体表现在哪些产品上面出现了问题
也就是我们从大到小区 深挖一些细节
最终还是回落到产品和直通车上面
产品跟直通车是最细微的一些指标
这些细微的指标才是我们能够具体去操作和改善的指标
那么产品分析它的路径是怎么样的
第一个 我们去看整个店铺里面
单品曝光量高点击访客反馈等等这些数据 比如说A产品
上个月效果非常好 那么
这个月效果非常差 为什么差呢
你就要去分析它的一个点击访客
以及它反馈哪个维度的数据在下降
然后再针对这些指标去分析 为什么它点击量减少了
是关键值排名下降吗
还是说它的一个所有的搜索关键词的搜索指数都在下降
也就是整个平台的热度都在下降
你要去细致的维度去分析
访客也是一样 反馈也是一样
你按照这个维度一个一个的拆解它的原因
拆解它的原因
然后再对里面的原因进行一个分析优化
就可以解决这个问题了
所以我们在优化的时候都是非常细致又微的
第二个就是自然流量占比
比如说你的这个A产品本身的自然流量可能降到90%
直通这流量可能降到10%
但是呢现在变成了这里全部的直通这流量可能降到30%
那么这里的自然流量可能70%
很有可能这里自然流量下降
为什么下降
会不会是因为它没有报名活动
会不会是因为它本身是报品
它变成了优品而已了
如果你本身是报品
是不是它本身的这个自然流量得到更多
但是你现在变成优品
甚至连优品都不是了
连优品都不是了
是不是自然流量就会出现暴跌
所以说这个自然流量的占比
也能够反馈出我们当前这个产品的具体的情况
刚才也讲了
第三个就是如果点击变少了
是不是你的关键词排名下降了
也就是你这个产品里面的多个关键词排名都在下降
这种情况也会导致你整个产品的数据暴跌
那么第四个就是优报品总量的变化
这里是多个产品在下降
而我们刚才我在这里讲的这个是
针对单品的变化
单品变化
这是多个产品的变化
这是单个产品的变化
所以说如果我们要更加详细的分析
那么就是从单品入手
多个单品积累起来就是多个单品决定了我们整个店铺的综合数据
所以说这是一环扣一环
而且它们之间都是关联性的
第四个就是直通车的数据分析
这里也是一样
主要是去看单品
它的曝光点击反客反馈这些数据
这里我们就不展开讲了
因为我们直通车的课程里面讲的非常的详细
第二个就是点击词是否发生变化
这个是被非常非常多的运营忽视的一个问题
这个问题影响询盘非常的大
比如说你本来这个A产品点击的词可能是B C D
这三个词转化都非常高
寻盘转化
订单
T2M转化非常高
但是呢下个月
A这个产品的点击词变成E F G
那么这几个词可能就是转化率非常低
寻盘订单还有T2M都是非常少的
所以他们的点击词发生了变化
也会导致你的寻盘T2M会发生改变的
所以我们在按周按月对比数据的时候
一定也要去对比我们现在的点击词的变化
因为这是直接影响寻盘转化的
有些词匹配的产品它转化高
有些词匹配这个产品它转化就低
这个逻辑一定要清楚
第三个就是点击国家是否方向改变
这个也是直接影响我们的寻盘转化的
比如说你A产品本来的点击的都是
美国英国澳大利亚
这些转化寻盘订单T2M都是非常好的
转化高
那么下一个月A产品的一个点击的国家
变成了沙特
墨西哥墨西哥还有就是越南
如果它的点击量都集中在这三个国家
或者是更多的这些非目标国家的时候
那么它的寻盘就少
那么它就很难成交了
是不是因为这个国家的点击变化
它整个自动转化就下降了
第四个就是点击人群标签是否发生的变化
比如说A这个产品本来点击的是
B C D定向标签里面的BCD这几个标签都是高点击
高点击高点击高悬盘
但是下个月A这个产品的标签变成了E F G
那么这些标签点击量也变得非常高了
然后BCD这些标签点击变少了
点击变少这里点击变高
那么就会导致A这个产品的循环就少了
理解吧
所以我们在使用自动车推广的时候
一定要注重点击词点击国家点击人群标签等等
这些数据的细小变化
只要它按周按月如果它变化大
那么它实际上对你的整个计划的
循环转化是影响非常大的
这些维度其实被很多人忽视了
这些维度其实就是决定着你循环转化的高低
一定要细致的去分析判断
然后做调整
针对这些指标调整就可以了
那么这节课我们就是讲关于店铺流量暴增暴跌
怎么样去分析
以及分析哪些指标
针对这些指标我们要采取具体的方法去改善
那么关于它的方法怎么应用
我们可以参考之前我们所学的内容
或者是你在这节课
听完之后所能够得到的启发
去应用这些方法去调整
然后再进行一个数据前后对比
就能够知道它的结果
以及它的有效性
只要有效的方法
你就把它记录下来
持续的去用这些方法就可以了
那么你的整个店铺将会越来越好
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见